[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا مجوز الاخبار
من الجزيره قال مصدر رسمي تركي للجزيره
انه تم ابلاغه الجانب الروسي بعدم قبول
تركيا الانتشار الشكليه لقوات النظام
السوري في مناطق ما تعرفوا بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه واوضح انه تم اعداده كافه
التجهيزات العسكريه واللوجستيه اللازمه
لتنفيذ العمليه العسكريه شماليه سوريا
وكان الناطق باسم الرئاسه التركي ابراهيم
قال ان تركيا لم تستهدف حتى الان اي جنود
امريكيين وروس وان هدف العمليه الوحيده هو
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه الموجوده في
شمال سوريا
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باتريك رايدر لانه الولايات المتحده خلصت
دورياتها شماليه سوريا واضاف ان واشنطن ما
زالت تركز على القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
في تغريده على تويتر قال حلف الناتو انه
عزز وجوده في جزؤه الشرقي بثمانيه مجموعات
قتاليه في بلغاريا والمجر وبولندا
ورومانيا وليتوانيا
واضف ان افراد هذه المجموعات من جنسيات
المختلفه وهم مستعدون للقتال وبانه وجودهم
يوضح ان الهجوم على حليف واحد هو هجوم على
الجميع
وقال الامين العام لخلف الناتو يانسز
طولكرم
يبحثون تسليما اوكرانيا منظومه الدفاع
باتريات المضاده للصواريخ واضاف انه
لضماني كفاءت هذه الانظمه المتطوره يجب
توفيره قطع الغيار اللازمه والذخيره
قال نائب رئيس مجلس
انه في حاله زود النيترو اوكرانيا بانظمه
باتريوت فستصبح تلك الانظمه هدفا مشروع
الجويه في اوكرانيا لا توجد له مخططات
الان لارساله بطاريات باتريوت الى
اوكرانيا
نقلت وكاله وبلومبرج عن الدبلوماسيين
قولهم من استمرار الجدري بين الاطراف
الاوروبيه بشان تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط
الروسي والمحادثات لا تزال عالقه وذلك قبل
اسبوعين من حضر اوروبا ورذات الخامر
الروسي
رساله لمنتدى اعمال الطاقه الروسيه
الصينيه الرابع ان الصين مستعده العمل مع
روسيا من اجل الدعم امن الطاقه في العالم
من جهته قال الرئيس الروسي في الرساله
المنتدى ان العقوبات ضد روسيا هي التي
ستهدد وضع الطاقه في العالم
نقل وكاله رويترز انا حزب الشيوعي الصيني
اكد على ضروره قمع عمليات التسلل والتخريب
من قبل القوى المعاديه وفقا للقانون وشدد
بيان للحزب عقب اجتماعي اللجنه السياسيه
والقانونيه المركزيه للحزب على ضروره قمع
ما سماها الاعمال غير القانونيه
والاجراميه التي تخل بالنظام الاجتماعي مع
المحافظه بجديه على الاستقرار الاجتماعيه
الشامل
وكانت مراسلته الجزيره قد افادت بان
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المطالبه برفع
العلاقات في مختلف المدن الصينيه توقفت
تعزيزات امنيه مشدده في العاصمه بيجين وفي
شانغهاي واظهرت صور انتشارا مكثفا لقوه
الشرطه في مدينه شنغهاي حاله دون خروج
احتجاجات مناهضه لقيودرون
زي ما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير